[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من واشنطن ومثول
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب امام
محكمه اتحاديه في العاصمه الامريكيه بتهم
التامر ضد الدوله الامريكيه وعرقله اجراء
رسمي وانتهاك الحقوق الانتخابيه
الى نيامي عاصمه النيجر التي شهدت اليوم
مظاهرات بمناسبه عيد الاستقلال هدف
المشاركون فيها تاييدا للانقلاب وضد اي
تدخل عسكري خارجي
وفي العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس
في ظل اجتماع حكومي اجتماع عقد في مدينه
اقدامس جدد خلاله عبد الحميد دبيبه رفض
المراحل الانتقاليه والحكومات الموازنه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه اللحظه
يمثل امام القضاء من جديد
اربع تهم امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في
واشنطن ابرزها التامر لتغيير نتائج
الانتخابات واقتحام الكونجرس وشرطه
العاصمه تقول للجزيره انها اعدت خطه امنيه
مشتركه لحفظ الامن وتحذر من احتمال وقوع
تحركات وانشطه مشبوهه
قبيل انتهاء مهله الاكواز لاستعاده نظام
الحكم في النيجر
سنه
تؤكد استعدادها لارسال قوات في حال قاره
المجموعه التدخل قاده الانقلاب يرفضون
عوده الرئيس المحتجز ويدعون الى تهيئه
الاجواء لانتقال سلمي واجراء انتخابات
والولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
يؤكدان ضروره الافراج عن الرئيس بازو
في ملف ازمه الغذاء العالميه وتداعيات
توقف صفقه الحبوب المنسقه الامميه تكشف ان
35 مليون شخص باتوا على حافه الجوع
وممكن يقول ان قصف صوامع اوكرانيا فاقم
الازمه عالميا ويتهم موسكو برفع امداداتها
للسوق بعد الانسحاب من مبادره الحبوب
ونائب المندوب الروسي ينفي ويتهم الغرب
بمراكمه فائض المخزونات بينما تعاني الدول
الناميه
مع استمرار الهجمات داخل الحدود الروسيه
موسكو تعلن احباطه هجوم بمسيرات في مقاطعه
كالوجا
تقول ان الهجمات ينفذها من سمتهم الثوار
الروس وفي الجوار الاوروبي فاجنر تجدد
مخاوف جناح الناتو الشرقي ليتوانيا تقول
ان وجود فاغنمر في بيلاروسيا خطر امني
اضافي ورئيس وزراء بولندا يقول ان هدف
تحريك مقاتل المجموعه يهدف لزعزعه
الاستقرار
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تداعيات المحتمله لمثول
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
مجددا امام القضاء الامريكي في قضيه وصفت
بالتهديد القضائي الاخطر
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم
السؤال الثاني ما ابرز التداعيات المحتمله
للحلقه الاحدث في مسلسل متاعب القانونيه
وجاءت النتائج على النحو التالي
44% قالوا ان حمله الرئاسيه ستتاثر سلبا
بينما راى قرابه 26% ان تشامب سيتمكن من
توظيف متاعبه القانونيه لدعم شعبيته اما
نحن ثلاثين في المئه فتوقعوا تعقد وضع
ترامب القانوني واحتمال ادانته وسجنه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعلات
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
البدايه من واشنطن اذن حيث يمثل الان
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب امام
المحكمه الفيدراليه في واشنطن لمواجهه
اربع تهم في قضيه سعيه لتغيير نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2020 ودوره في
احداث السادس من يناير كانون الثاني 2021
هذه صور مباشره نشاهدها من المحكمه وقد
وصل الرئيس الامريكي قبل قليل الى هذه
المحكمه ليمثل امامها وسوف يسال اذا ما
كان مذنبا ام لا
وبالتاكيد سيجيب بانه غير مثله
المزيد من اللوائح الاتهام في وجه دونالد
ترامب للمره الثانيه خلال اربعه اشهر يمثل
امام محكمه فيدراليه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق والاكثر اثاره للجدل ليواجه لائحه
ثقيله تتعلق بتهم توجه اليه بشان السعي
لافساد انتخابات رئاسه عام 2020 واقتحام
الكونجرس في السادس من يناير التالي في
خمس واربعين صفحه جاءت وثيقه المحكمه التي
يقول مدعون فيها ان ثمه مؤامره منسقه عبر
عده ولايات ساق فيها ترامب وحلفائه
ادعاءات يعلمون بطلانها بوجود تزوير في
الانتخابات لتعطيل الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
سعيا للبقاء في السلطه حتى الان يواجه
ترامب 3 لوائح اتهام جنائيه تحوي مجتمعه
78 تهمه احداها تتعلق فيدراليا بجهود
مزعومه لالغاء انتخابات 2020 ولعب دور في
اعمال الشغب في السادس من يناير تحت هذه
اللائحه اربع يبلغ الحد الاقصى لاجمالي
عقوباتها خمسه وثلاثين عاما لائحه الاتهام
الثانيه فيدراليه ايضا وتتعلق بالتعامل مع
الوثائق السريه وتندرج تحتها 40 تهمه يصل
مجموع الحدود القصوى لعقوبات هذه التهم
الى السجن خمسه وثلاثين عاما لائحه
الاتهام الثالثه غير فيدراليه ولكنها في
نيويورك وتتعلق بتقديم مدفوعات ماليه
مقابل الصمت وتندرج تحتها 34 تهمه ويبلغ
الحد الاقصى لعقوبات هذه التهم السجن
اربعه اعوام اي ان اجمالي الحدود القصوى
لعقوبات لوائح الاتهام الثلاث حتى الان
يقاربوا ثلاثه ارباع قرن في السجن يدفع
ترامب دعائيا بان ما يواجهه مؤامره تستهدف
النيل من حظوظه الوفيره في الانتخابات
المقبله وهي الانتخابات التي يسعى المحقق
الخاص جاك سميث كما قال لتفادي تاثرها
بالمحاكمه الراهنه غير ان تر امب يترقب
ايضا جوله تحقيق جديده في جورجيا نهايه
هذا الشهر حيث ينتظر ان تعلن مدعيه نتيجه
تحقيقها في شان ضغوط يشتبه في ان يكون
الرئيس الامريكي السابق مارسها لتغيير
نتيجه الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2020 في
الولايه
هذه اذا صور مباشره من مقر المحكمه
الفيدراليه في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
تشكل هناك اجراءات امنيه خاصه في ظل وجود
الرئيس السابق سابق في في هذه المحكمه
هذا وقالت اداره الشرطه واشنطن للجزيره
قالت انها تعمل عن كثب مع الامن الرئاسي
والعديد من الوكالات الامنيه الفيدراليه
لتوفير الامن والسلامه خلال مثول الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه اليوم
واضافت انه من المتوقع اغلاق بعض الطرق
وتعطل حركه المرور لفتره قصيره تزامنا مع
مثول الرئيس السابق امام المحكمه
وادعت شرطه العاصمه الجميع الى توخي
الحيطه والحذر والابلاغ عن اي تحركات او
انشطه مشبوهه
من امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في واشنطن
ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره احمد هزيم احمد
نرى يعني جموع الناس لا شك ان هذه
المحاكمه تحظى باهتمام كبير نود ان تصف
لنا المشهد حيث انت
[موسيقى]
انام عثمان اهتمام كبير من قبل الامريكيين
الذين توافدوا هنا بالمئات
ليكونوا شاهدين على هذه اللحظه التاريخيه
في التاريخ السياسي الامريكي مثول رئيس
سابق للمره الثانيه
امام محكمه فيدراليه يواجه تواما جنائيه
هذه المره تتعلق باحداث اقتحام الكونغرس
في السادس يناير من عام 2020 تشاهد عثمان
هنا خلفي وعلى الجانب حضور من او مزيج من
الحضور ومن الصحفيين طواقم وسائل اعلام
بعضهم من انصار الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب بعضهم من اشد معارضيه بعضهم
فقط جاء ليكون شاهدا على هذه اللحظه كما
ذكرت الرئيس الامريكي الان السابق موجود
في قاعه المحكمه هو وفريقه القانوني
بانتظار ان تتلى عليه لائحه التهم
المتعلقه باحداث السادس من يناير ودوره في
قلب نتائج الانتخابات فريق ايضا بقياده
المحقق الخاص جاك سميث ايضا موجود في قاعه
المحكمه ان الرئيس الامريكي في هذه اللحظه
عثمان هو
رهن الاعتقال او رهن الاحتجاز من قبل
السلطات الفيدراليه بانتظار ان تتلى عليه
التهم ان يدفع هو ببراءته كما هو متوقع
ومن ثم تتخذ القاضيه القرار حول شروط
اخلاء سبيلهم اخلاء فرض كفاله لاخلاء
سبيله ان تتم الاقلاع عنه كما حدث في
المحكمه الفتراليه في ميامي دون شروط بشرط
واحد فقط هو ان لا يتحدث لاي من الشهود او
المتهمين الاخرين في هذه القضيه نحن
بانتظار ما يترشح عن هذه المحكمه وما اذا
كان الرئيس كما هو متوفي متوقع قد دفع
ببراءته ومن ثم سيستقل موكبه دائما مره
اخرى الى المطار وعائدا الى منتجعه في
نيوجيرسي عثمان كما قلت هذه هي المره
الثانيه التي يمثل يمثل فيها امام المحكمه
هل سوف يكون هناك اي شيء مختلف عن ما حدث
في المره السابقه
حتى اللحظه ما لدينا من مؤشرات ومتردد في
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه من انه قد تم
اتخاذ بصمات الرئيس الامريكي وهو كما حدث
في محكمه ميامي لن تؤخذ له صور الشخصيه من
كل الزوايا لانه اجراء يقول المحققون بانه
اجراء يستخدمون هذه الصور في حاله لدى
المتهم بالفرار بعد الاخلاء سبيله وعدم
وقرر عدم المثول امام المحاكمه في اثناء
المرافعات لكن الرئيس الامريكي وجهه معروف
كما يقولون ولا يحتاجون الى اخذ هذه الصور
من كل الزوايا لكي يتم نشرها عن مراكز
الشرطه حول حول البلاد للقبض على المتهمين
عاده بعد ان يكونوا قد فشلوا في المثول
امام المحكمه امام المحكمه اثناء
المرافعات وضع في غرفه صغيره
هي الغرفه التي يتم احتجاز المتهمين فيها
ان يكونوا رهن الاعتقال قبل مثولهم امام
المحكمه ما حدث في المحكمه الفيدراليه
هناك في ميامي قبل سته اسابيع والان هو
وفريقه القانوني وموجودون داخل المحكمه
بانتظار ان تتلى عليهم اللائحه اي بمعنى
ان الاجراءات القضائيه لا تزال هي كما حدث
في محكمه ميامي بعض الخبراء القانونيين
عثمان الذين نتحدثوا الى وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه يرون في ان هذه القضيه قضيه
السادس من يناير قضيه عزمه على اقل بنتائج
الانتخابات لصالحي والبقاء في السلطه رغم
خسارته الانتخابات
وعزمه ذلك وهو يعلم ان ليس هناك تزوير كما
يقول الادعاء في هذه الديباجه اي ديباجه
لائحه الاتهام هي تهمه اخطر بكثير من تلك
التي يواجهها في في فلوريدا في ميامي
والتي تتعلق بمساله الوثائق السريه اي
بمعنى ان حظوظ الادلاع حسب بعض بعض
القانونين لنتحدث الى وسائل الامن
الامريكيه حدود الادعاء في هذه القضيه
اكبر على اهتمام الامريكي في هذه القضيه
يقولون انه سيكون اكبر بكثير اهتمام الراي
العام الامريكي من قضيه الوثائق السريه
ولانق هذه القضيه هي قضيه فريده من نوعها
الوثائق السريه نتذكر نحن عثمان ان بعد ان
تم الكشف عن ان ترامب على بعض
الوثائق السريه في ماللاجو
ظهر ان هناك عديد من السياسيين لديهم ايضا
اوراق سريه في مراكز اقامتهم وفي منازلهم
لم يسلموها الى الارشيف اي ان حصوله على
هذه الوثائق دون اذن لم يكن شيئا فريدا
اما ان يكون رئيس سابق قد خسر الانتخابات
وقد حاول بكل جوده هو وفريق محيط به قلب
نتيجه هذه الانتقادات اي قلب الديمقراط
الخيار الديمقراطي للناخ الاميركي هذا لم
يحدث من قبل في التاريخ الامريكي وما يجعل
ان هذه المحاكمه هنا في العاصمه واشنطن في
المحكمه على قرب من مبنى الكابيت والعم
مبنى الكونجرس الامريكي هي المحاكمه التي
تحظى باهتمام اكبر مدى الراي العام
الامريكي بلا شك هل هل حظي باي تعامل خاص
كونه كان رئيسا للولايات المتحده ام عمل
كاي اي اي متهم عادي
بالنسبه لما رشحه وعامل كما عمل اثناء
محاكمه ميامي ليس
الحكم على ان هذه المعامله هي معامله
امتيازيه هو حكم يعتمد على كيف ينظر اليه
الشخص الذي يرى هذه المحاكمه لم تؤخذ له
صور من كل الزوايا من المعضره في ذلك بانه
امتياز قدم للرئيس الامريكي لم توضع
الاصفاد في يده هناك من يرى ان هذا ايضا
امتياز قدم للرئيس الامريكي السابق حيث ان
المتهمين الاخرين في تهم جنائيه اخرى يتم
وضع الاطفال في ايديهم اذا اخذنا بهذه
بهذه
الامتيازات او هذه الاستثناءات التي حظي
بها الرئيس الامريكي يمكن القول بان هناك
بعض التمييز بحق كونه شخصيه
معروفه وكونه رئيس امريكي سابق لكن هذه
الاجراءات هي اجراءات ثانويه عثمان مثوله
شخصيا والشرط والاصرار على مثوله في هذه
المحكمتين الفيدراليتين هو الامر الرئيسي
الذي ترى وزاره العدل وترى سلطات القانونه
في الولايات المتحده انه لا يمكن ان تميزه
في هذا الاجراء لا يمكن ان تستثنيه من هذا
الاجراء وضعه رسميا وقانونيا تحت في رهن
الاعتقال قبيل مثولي هذا المحكمه هو
الاجراء الذي تقول السلطات القانونيه انه
سيكون استثناء لو لم تقم به اتجاه الرئيس
السابق اي بمعنى انها تريد ان تضع تضعه
ضمن المسار الاجرائي القضائي الاساسي او
الضروري التي تنفذه على بقيه من يتوجه لهم
تهم من طابع جنائي هو ما ارادته وزاره
العدل الامريكيه واراده ارادت سلطات انفاذ
القانون هنا في الولايات المتحده بان يكون
نافذا ايضا على الرئيس السابق هذه ثالث
قضيه اكثر من 70 تهمه ومن المتوقع ان تكون
هناك قضيه رابعه تتعلق بالانتخابات في
جورجيا ايضا
ما الذي تعنيه هذه القضايا لسير العمليه
الانتخابيه وهو الذي يرشح نفسه عن الحزب
الجمهوري في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
عثمان اذا اخذنا استطلاعات الراي الاخيره
التي ايضا تحدث عنها الرئيس السابق قبيله
مغادرته مقر اقامته هناك في نيوجيرسي
متوجه الى واشنطن تحدث هو
[موسيقى]
ذكر في مشاركه على حسابه على انه يحتاج
الى ادانه اخرى فقط ليضمن فوزه
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله بمعنى ان
استطلاعات الراي تظهر تقارب كثير بين
الرئيس السابق كمرشح للحزب الجمهوري
والرئيس الحالي جو بايدن كمرشح للحزب
الديمقراطي بعد ان تمت ادانته في محاكمه
في محاكمه ميامي هناك في فلوريدا على قضيه
الوثائق السريه اي بمعنى ان الناخب
الجمهوري حسب بعض التحليلات يقولون ان
الناخب الجمهوري يلتف اكثر حول او التف
اكثر حول الرئيس السابق بعد توجيه التهامي
اليه باعتبار ان هذه التهم او هي التهم
استقصاد سياسي او توامداد سياسي وان
تسعه وستين او 69 بالمئه تقريبا من
الجمهوريين من الناخبين الجمهوريين لا
يزالون يؤمنون بان الانتخابات عام 2020
كانت مزوره لصالح الرئيس الحالي بمعنى
اتهام الرئيس الامريكي بتهم تتعلق بامور
الناخب الجمهوري او غالبيه الناخبين
الجمهوريين يعتقدون انها ان ترامب هو
المحق فيها لا شك ستقرب هؤلاء الناخبين
اكثر فاكثر من الرئيس السابق دونالدز
شكرا لك احمد ابقى معنا وانت تتابع هناك
من المحكمه الفدراليه في واشنطن وارحب
بضيوفنا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
من واشنطن الصحفي وعضو اللجنه الوطنيه
للحزب الجمهوري ومن واشنطن
مدير مكتبه
جوزها بايدن السابق اهلا وسهلا بكم هذه
يعني هذا يعيده للاجواء يعني يعيد اجواء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في واشنطن عندما كنت
اتحدث اليكم
لساعات حول الانتخابات الرئاسيه ولكن يبدو
مع شخصيه مثل دونالد ترامب لا تستطيع ان
تغمض عينيك او مش هتقدر تغمض عينيه كما
يقال دكتور خليل اليس كذلك احداث كثيره
ومتتابعه ما الذي سوف يعنيه او تعنيه هذه
المحاكمه وهذه القضايا لدونالد ترامب في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
اهلا بك استاذ عثمان بكل ساده الضيوف وكل
المشاهدين انا اعتقد نحن ايذاء فصل جديد
في ملحمه ترامب القضائيه هذه هي المحاكمه
الثالثه والثانيه الفدراليه التي يتهم
فيها ترامب بتهمه هي من اخطر التهم التي
لم تحدث من قبل في التاريخ الامريكي
بيتكلم على رئيس يتم التهامه بمحاوله
القيام بانقلاب سياسي على انتخابات
الرئاسيه عام 2020 والتامر من اجل تغيير
نتائجها وهذا يعتبر اتهام خطير الى حد
بعيد اذا تم اثباته بشكل اخر خلال
المحاكمه الفتره المقبله وهذا يعتبر اضافه
جديده لمسلسل الاثاره فيما يتعلق
بانتخابات الاسيويه الامريكيه القادمه نحن
ايذاء مرشح هو المتقدم المتفوق الى حد بعت
السباق الانتخابي بنتكلم على الاقل
هو 57% على اقل من من الناخبين الجمهوريين
يدعموا ترامب الفرق بينه وبين اقرب
منافسيه هو حاكم ولايه هاروندي سندس حوالي
40% اخر استطاع على الرائي قبل حوالي
اسبوع اعطت رقم 57% مقابل 17% لصالح نتكلم
على مرشح جمهوري مكتسح الى حد بعيد هناك
دعم كبير جدا له
كثير جدا من الجمهوريين يعتبرون انه ما
حدث في 2020 يعتبر خساره لبيض ويعتبر بيض
رئيس غير شرعي حسب استطل السنين قبل يومين
يقول سبعه من كل عشر جمهوريين يعتقدون
فوزه وغير فوز غير مشروع وبالتالي ترامب
والحق بالرئاسه وبالتالي بنتكلم على اجواء
سياسيه ساخنه بنتكلم على الاقل الان 78
تهمه جزء منها فيدرالي جزء منها محل على
مستوى ولايه نيويورك وبالتالي والذين طبعا
في انتظار محاكمه او قضيه محاوله تاثير
على نتائج انتخابات فولات جورجيا بنتكلم
على محاكمه تاريخيه بكل ما تحملوا الكلام
المعنى رئيس سابق يتعارض هذا يعني ان
امريكا تواجه بشكل او اخر ازمه سياسيه وقد
تكون كمان ايضا ازمه استرالي وتم الحكم
على ترامب في قادم الايام بالسجن مثلا سوف
سوف
مدى حقيته في الترشح الر ومدى قدرته على
الحكم اذا تم الحكم عليه بالفعل يعني
في الانتخابات الرئيسيه المقبله وهو في
السجن هل سيحدث ذلك ام لا نحن ايذاء وضع
تاريخي المعنى نتيجه لهذه القضيه المستمره
فيما يتعلق
لا ادري اذا كنت انت شخصيا من مؤيد ترامب
الجمهوريين ولكن لماذا كل هذه المحاكمات
او او كل هذه التهم الخطيره واخطرها هي
التي يواجهها اليوم لا تؤثر في الناخب
الجمهوري وحيث يبدو ان معظم الجمهوريين ما
زالوا رغم كل شيء يؤيدون دونالد ترامب
مرشحا للرئاسه عن الحزب الجمهوري
في الحقيقه هذا سؤال يطرح على زملائي اذا
انا لست في الاوساط
الديمقراطيه لذلك لا اعرف لماذا هم يزعمون
هذه المزاعم على مستوى هناك مدعي محلي
يواجه ترامب هناك قضيه الوثائق والمستندات
بالنسبه الى ما اخذه معه السيد ترامب من
وثائق ما كان يجب ان ياخذها معه لانها
مصنفه هذه القضيه غير قويه والان لدينا
جاك سميث وهو المحقق الخاص في هذه القضيه
يقوم بامر جديد من خلال لائحه الاتهام هذه
ويمكن النقد هذه اللائحه اذا ما اثبت
ببساطه ان السيد ترامب كان لديه اسس
اعتقاد ان هناك امور غير طبيعيه حصلت
اثناء الانتخابات وادت الى النتيجه التي
حصلت لا يهم ما يقوله المحقق الخاص المهم
ما اذا كان السيد ترامب يعتقد حقا ان هذه
الامر حصلت بالفعل وراينا ادله ان السيد
ترامب بالفعل يؤمن بذلك هناك ازمه سياسيه
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الا وهي
استغلال النظام القضائي من قبل مناويئي
الرئيس ترامب في خلال رئاسته وحتى في خلال
الحمله الحاليه هذا ما يجب ان يحقق بشانه
وهذا ما يجب ان يزج الناس بشانه في السجون
وهذا ما يجب ان نتحدث عنه ويتحدث عنه
الجميع ليس جهود الرئيس ترامبو لكي يعود
الى رئاسه مجددا بل جهود
المعارضين لترامب من خلال ما يقومون به
هذه هي الازمه
هل هذه محاكمه
مسيسه والغرض منها هو منع ترامب من الترشح
للرئاسه وهي ليست مبنيه على اسس قانونيه
يمكن من خلالها ادانه الرئيس السابق
مع كل احترامي لزميلي
ولكنني لا اتفق معه ابدا ابدا اعتقد انه
يتفادى الحديث عن الحقيقه يتناسى الحقيقه
ايه وهي الا وهي 36 قضيه كلها لصالح اداره
بايدن وان بايدن يكسب في الانتخابات
السابقه هذه القضايا قائمه وهي سليمه ونحن
نتحدث عن وضع نشاهد فيه الرئيس في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه رئيس الا وهو
ترامب قام بخرق القانون ليس فقط
اسس القانون او روح القانون
والعقيده القانونيه المرتبطه بالدستور
ولكنه ايضا قام بخرق القوانين بطريقه
مباشره الجميع يتحدث
الان
والجميع نحن هنا جميعنا كنا نتحدث في
السادس من يناير ايضا الرئيس ترامب هو من
قاد الحركه التمرديه وهو يجب ان يحاسب
اتفاجا ان الامر تطلب كل هذا الوقت ولكن
يمضي قدما كما يجب الغريب بالنسبه الى هذا
الموضوع هو ان الفزبه الجمهوري يبدو وكانه
يتفادى قول الحقيقه يتفادى كل الوقائع وكل
ما حصل في خلال السنوات الثماني الماضيه
وهذا مؤسف بالفعل ان يحاولوا ان يستمروا
بهذه
الاكاذيب الكبرى بالنسبه الى هذه القضيه
وبالتالي هناك وجه سياسي ولكن الوجه
السياسي لا يظهر في هذه القضايا الثلاثه
الوارده في لائحه الاتهام الدكتور خليل
كنت تتحدث عن اح صائيات فيما يتعلق بتاييد
داخل الحزب الجمهوري لماذا لم يتمكنوا
منافسوه داخل الحزب من يعني
ان ان يفوزوا بشعبيه اكبر شخص له شعبيه
كبيره مثل سانتيس او حتى مايك بنز لماذا
هذا تاييد الكبير برايك داخل
الحزب الجمهوري
انا اعتقل لابد ان نفرق بين امرين الامر
لا المتعلق بالترام كشخص وبالترامبيه
كظاهره نحن في امريكا حاليا هناك
حالا من الصعود اليمين سياسي بشكل او باخر
ترامب يمثل وقمه قمه جبل الثالث هذا
اليمين هذه اليمين لديه افكار متعلقه
بالموقف من الحكم الفيدراليه الموقف من
الاجانب الموقف من المهاجرين موقف من
الازمه الاقتصاديه الموقف من الحروب
الخارجيه لامريكا هذا هذا التيار او هذه
الظاهره الترامبيه تمثل قاعده انتخابيه
مهمه جدا لترامب ترامب باستطاعها بشكل ان
ينجح في تعبئه هذه القاعده الجمهوريه لحزب
الجمهوري في حاله فراغ قيادي بشكل او باخر
ليس هناك امكانيه للشخص ان يقوم بمنافسه
منافسه ترامب ترامب بيستخدم خطاب شعبوي
عاطفي الى حد بعيد طبعا هو يلعب على مظالم
تاريخيه موجوده لدى الطبقه الوسطى
الامريكيه خاصه في وجود نوع من التوحش
الراسمالي نيو ليبرالي الذي اثرت بشكل على
مستوى الحاله الاقتصاديه في امريكا خلال
العقود الماضيه وبالتالي هناك مظالم
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
باستثماريه بشكل باخر من اجل ان يقوم
بتعبيتها السياسيه رغم انه يعتبر مستفيد
من هذه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه لانه يعتبر رجل
الاعمال كبير جدا لديه طبعا مشاكل فيما
يتعلق بثروته لكنه بشكل او باخر مستفيد
النظام الراسماليه لكنه واستخدم ويستغل كل
ما يتعلق الاقتصاديه الاجتماعيه كي يعبر
الطبقه جزء عدد الجمهوريه الامر الثاني
متعلق في رايي بما استطاع ان يغرزه في
نفوس وفي عقول الجمهوريين ان الانتخابات
فرقت منه في عام 2020
سنعود مره اخرى الى احمد هزيمه الموجود
امام
المحكمه
هل هل من جديد طبعا نعلم انه غير مسموح
بالتصوير فقط هناك
متابعون اعلاميون داخل المحكمه ينقلون ما
يجري يحاولون نقله بدقه ولكن ماذا لديك
احمد
عثمان كما ذكرت انت بعض الاعلاميين
الموجودين في المحكمه سمعناهم يخبرون
زملائهم من ان الرئيس الامريكي ادى القسم
استمع الى لائحه التهم ودافع ببراءته في
هذه اللائحه اي ان كما هو متوقع دفع
ببراءته من التهم الموجهه اليه والان يتم
بحث عمليه
الافراج عن هل ستكون بكفاله ام لا لكن
الحدث الرئيسي الذي جاء ترامبليه قد حدث
بالفعل تم تلاوه التهم عليه ودفع هو
ببراءته عثمان
نعم يعني ويبدو ان مؤيديه يعني يهتفون
بتاييده واذا كنت قد تحدثت اليهم
كما قال الدكتور خليل يؤمنون تماما بان
دونالد ترام تعرض لمؤامره في الانتخابات
رغم كل الاحكام التي صدرت لصالح جو بايدن
في حقيقه الامر
نعم عثمان هم مؤمنون ومقتنعون تماما بان
ما حدث للرئيس الامريكي السابق والترام
عام 2020 كان مؤامره للاطاحه به وان
الانتخابات كانت مزوره وان الرئيس الحالي
هو رئيس غير شرعي وحتى بما يتعلق بهذه
القضيه وحتى اذا كانوا لا يعتقدون بان هذا
اذا كانوا مخطئين كما يقولون فان حتى هذه
القضيه لا يجب ان تكون تهم موجه الي لانه
مقفول بحريه التعبير المكفوله بالدستور
محمي عفوا بحريه التعبير المكفوره بدستور
وحصانه الخطاب السياسي المكفول دستوريا
ايضا بمعنى انهم مقتنعون مؤمنون ان الرئيس
الامريكي تعرض لمؤامره اطاحته من الرئاسه
وحرمته من فتره ثانيه لكن حتى ان كانوا
مخطئين في هذا الطرح فهم ايضا يعتقرون بان
التهم ما كان يجب ان توجه اليه لان ما
قاله سواء من فتره اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع
حتى احداث الحادي احداث السادس من يناير
هو حريه تعبير وخطاب سياس سياسي محصنين
ومكفولين وفق الدستور عندما يخرج من
المحكمه هل من المتوقع ان يذهب الى المطار
مباشره ام ام يعني سيلقي خطابا ومن
المعروف ان يعني بنسبه وتناسب مؤيدوه في
العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن ليسوا كثيرين
لا يتوقع يعني توقف الرئيس الامريكي للقاء
خطاب او لقاء او لقاء مناصرين لنتجمع هنا
يتوقع ان يخرج المبنى المحكمه باتجاه مطار
العاصمه المحلي ومن ثم
يستقلته الخاصه في العوده الى الى
نيوجيرسي بحيث يقيم هناك عثمان شكرا احمد
نعود اليك لاحقا وان نعود للدكتور خليل
نعم دكتور خليل كنت تتحدث عن مناصري ترامب
قبل ان نقاطعك ونذهب الى احمد هزيم
وبالتالي يؤمنون تماما انه يتعرض للمؤامره
هو
يعني قال مره انه يمكنه ان يخرج الى
نيويورك في ساحه لا ادري ربما افينيو حيث
برجه المعروف
ويطلق النار على احدهم ولن يؤثر ذلك على
تاييد مناصريه
هذا صحيح هذا يعكس الحدي بعيد اولا نوع من
الثقه بالذات الى حد الغرور عثمان وفي نفس
الوقت كمان استهانه بكل ما يتعلق بالقضاء
الامريكي ونحن نرى ذلك حاليا يعني هو لا
يكترث على الاطلاق بوجود هذه اللوحه
الاتهام ضده رغم انها جديه لحد بعيد خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالاته اليوم لانه بنتكلم على
كما قلنا قبل قليل لاول مره يتم اتهام
رئيس امريكي بمحاوله القيام من انقلاب عن
نتائج الانتخابات الامريكيه والتامر من
اجل تغيير هذه النتائج بشكل كبير جدا ولا
يكترث هذه المساله يحول كل هذه الامور
لصالحه بشكل او باخر هو بارع في ذلك
واستاذ في ذلك فيما يتعلق بكيفيه
الاستفاده سياسيا من كل هذه المحاكمات من
اجل باعتبار ضحيه للديمقراطيين ضحيه
لبايدن ويتم توظيف ذلك سياسيا وماديا ايضا
ونعلم جميعا عثمان انه على مدار اخر ست
شهور منذ بدء هذه الملحمه القضائيه جمع
على الاقل ما يقرب من حوالي 54 مليون
دولار فيما يتعلق بحملات الانتخابيه طبعا
جزء كبير من هذه الاموال يذهب الان فيما
يتعل تسديد فواتير المحامين
في هذه المساله لكنه ايضا يستثمر ذلك فيما
يتعلق بجمع تبرعات الحيوانات الانتخابيه
ترامب بطبيعته شخصيه قادره على التوظيف كل
ما يتعلق بمشاكل القضائيه سياسيا هو
يستخدم كل هذه المساله المسائل فيما يتعلق
يعني تعبئه القاعده الجمهوريه لصالحه
وراينا ذلك على مدار اخر اربع شهور يعني
مثلا بعد انتخابات التجديد النصفي في في
نوفمبر الماضي كان هناك توقع بانه ترامب
شبه انتهى لماذا لانه لم يحدث ما يتحدث
عنه فيما يتعلق بالريد ويف او الموجه
الحمراء التي كان يعني يعد بها الجمهوريين
فيما يتعلق بالسيطره الكامله على مجلس
الكونجرس النواب والشيوخ لكن هذا طبعا لم
يحدث وكان هناك نوع من اللوم ونوع من
الغضب والرفض الترامب بعد بدء هذه
المحاكمات في ابريق الماضي حدث تحول جذري
فيما يتعلق في الموقف من الترامب صعود
هائل شعبيته الجمهوريين صعود الحيوانات
الانتخابيه وزياده في حجم الاموال التي
يتم جمعها فيما يتعلق بهذه المساله
وبالتالي ترامب بارع في هذه المساله يعني
هو جاءت له على طبق طبق من ذهب هذه
المحاكمات من اجل ان يقوم باعاده احياء
نفسه مره اخرى وطرح نفسي بعتبرين مرشحا ان
لم يكن الوحيد على الاقل الاكثر تنافس
القدره على منافسه بايدن خاصه فيما يتعلق
بخسر في ظل يعني ضعف اداء بيضه اقتصاديا
وسياسيا وعدم وجود رضا كبيره الى حد بعيد
على هذا الاداء سيد بيتر رعب اريد ان
اخذها كمجددا الى كان يقولها السيد جون
بولجر عن ان
الجمهوريين يتجاهلون الحقيقه وليست
الحقيقه هي بالفعل ان هناك قضايا كثيره
يعني ذهب ترامب ومناصريه ومؤيدوه
في مسار قانوني ولكنهم خسروا هذه القضايا
لصالح الديمقراطيين
بحكم المحكمه فلماذا لا يعترف الجمهوريون
بهذه الحقيقه
ويصرون على ان ترامب تعرض لمؤامره في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
هناك
ثلاثه وستون قضيه
معظمها لم يكن فيها ادله
القضاه لم يقولوا انهم لم يجدوا الادله في
بعض الحالات وجدوا الادله ولكن في حالات
متعدده قالوا ان الناس الذين تقدموا
بالتهم لم يكن يحق لهم القيام بذلك اذا
بالنسبه الى الاصوات لو كانت باتجاه اخر
كان عاد الرئيس ترامب الى سده الرئاسه اذا
كانت النتيجه متقاربه وبالتالي مبعث القلق
كان حقيقيا بالنسبه الى دقه نتيجه
الانتخابات خصوصا بالنظر الى
الحرمان من التصويت في خلال
جائحه كورونا عدد كبيرا من اوراق الاقتراع
ذهبت ولا نعرف اين
ذهبت ولكن دونالد ترامب هو
يقود حمله مجددا
للانتخابات الرئاسيه وهو يود ان يصل الى
سده الرئاسه ولذلك دعم الرئيس ترامب لا
يزال قويا وبقي قويا بعد انتخابات 2020
اذا الاموال لا تزال تجمع لا يزال هو
يتزعم الحزب الجمهوري عدد كبير من مناصريه
وحتى بعض المعارضين لترامب يتفقون ان
الشعب الامريكي يرى هذه الهجمات المستمره
والمستعره على الرئيس ترامب من وزاره
العدل سواء كنا نتحدث عن تحقيقات او عن
لوائح اتهام وكلها جزء من خطه
الديمقراطيين للوصول الى ترامب لا ينظرون
الى ذلك على انه تدابير قانونيه قضائيه
عادله هناك بعض التدابير القانونيه ولكن
هذه اللوائح الاتهاميه يمكن ان تنقض على
سبيل المثال
نائب الرئيس السابق كان يمكن ان توجه اليه
لوائح الاتهام عندما رفض نتائج الانتخابات
وفي فلوريدا كان هناك تقارب هناك تعليقات
ايضا على مستوى
المحكمه العليا وقيل ان الرئيس بوش اعطيت
له الرئاسه ولم يكسب في الانتخابات وفي
هذه الحاله في حاله المحقق الخاص جاك سميث
ما قاله يمكن ان ينطبق على الجور وعلى
ديمقراطيين اخرين هذه سابقه خطره نراها
بالنسبه الى ما حصل فقط
نشير الى هذا العاجل الذي تشاهدونه ايضا
المحكمه الفيدراليه تحدد موعد جلسه
الاستماع القادمه في الثامن والعشرين من
الشهر الجاري سيد جون بولجر اعلم انك سيد
بيتر
يمكنكم الاستمرار في الجدل حول تفاصيل ما
جرى الى كريسماس المقبل وبالتالي لن نفعل
ذلك ولكن اذا سمحت ان استفزك بعض الشيء
واقول لك الا يتعامل يعني صعب عليك ان
تقول انت ذلك ولكن الا يتعامل دون ترامب
بذكاء كبير مع كل ما يقذفه نحوه الحزب
الديمقراطي
في البدايه
زميلي بيتر قدم سلسله من الامور التي لن
اغوص فيها الواحده والاخرى لانقضها ولكن
اقول رئيس السابق المثير للاهتمام ان بيتر
يقول الرئيس ترامب ولكن اود ان اقول
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب الذي خسر
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في العام 2020 ليس
ساذجا هو في الاخبار في كل يوم منذ استقل
المصعد في يونيو
2015 وبالتالي انا اعطيه هذه النقطه
الافضليه على انه يسوق لنفسه بشكل جيد
ولكنه ليس قائدا لا يتمتع بالاخلاق
السياسيه والحزب والجمهوريه وبعد كل هذه
الانشطه والتي في مرات متعدده
الاشخاص او الذين عينهم ترامب بنفسه هم
يقودون هذه التحقيقات والاشخاص الذين
عينهم بنفسه في وزاره العدل هم يقودون هذه
القضايا نظروا في الحقائق والوقائع وادت
الى لائحه الاتهام ولوائح الاتهام هذه من
كان ليظن ان الوثائق لم تكن مضبوطه كما
يجب ولكن
دائما يود ان يقوم بالامور بطريقه مختلفه
وبالتالي اعتقد ان الحزب جمهوري مع نسبه
57 بالمئه دعم لدونالد ترامب يجب ان ينظر
الى الذات ويقول كل شخص في الحزب الجمهوري
هل يمكنني ان اقول لاطفالي ان هذا المدعي
وهذا الشخص الذي يكذب هو قائد هو زعيم كيف
لهم ان يقولوا ذلك لاطفالهم ما يجب ان
يقولوه هو انه عكس
مقابل وايد
والاجهاض غير القانوني باضافه الى الضرائب
وما قام به لاحقا اذا هذا ما يجب ان يقوله
الناس عوضا عن القول ان هذا الشخص هو
القائد والزعيم جو بايدن امضى السنوات
الثلاث الاخيره من عهدته في محاوله منه
لكي يعيد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
الساحه الدوليه ويعزز اسس الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والبنى التحتيه في
الولايات المتحده لمستقبلنا وللاجيال
المستقبليه وهذه التشريعات من الحزبين
التي مررها لذلك انا سعيد في دعم
للديمقراطيين والحزب الديمقراطي ان يمكنني
ان اقول بشكل فخور وانا مفتخر انني صوتت
حسنا نعود مره اخرى الى احمد هزيم الموجود
امام المحكمه
الفيدراليه هل من جديد احمد
[موسيقى]
نعم عثمان
حتى اللحظه من داخل المحكمه من القاضيه
كما فعلت القاضيه هناك في فلوريدا امرت
الرئيس الامريكي السابق بعدم التحدث الى
الشهود لكن ليس واضحا حتى اللحظه ما اذا
كان الافراج عنه سيتم بلا كفاله كما حدث
هناك في المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي لكن
بعض الخبراء القانونيه يدفعون بهذا
الاتجاه كي لا تكون هذه
الاجراءات متناقضه بين محكمه واخرى خصوصا
وانا الرئيس الامريكي محاط بخدمه شرطه ابي
عناصر من الخدمه السريه
وتحركاتي كلها معروفه
لجهاز الخدمه السريه بمعنى معروفه للحكومه
الامريكيه وسلطات انفاذ القانون ولا ليس
هناك ما يجعل يخشى تخشاه هذه السلطات من
ان يقوم الرئيس الامريكي بالهرب او
بمغادره البلاد دون اذن
كلها معروفه حتى اللحظه هو دفع ببراءته
القاضيه امرته بعدم الحديث الى الشهود
لم يغادر مبنى المحكمه بعد حسب ما لدينا
حسب اخر ما لدينا من معلومات قد يغادرها
في اي لحظه اذا تم حسم مساله الافراج عنه
بكفاله او من دون كفاله عثمان شكرا احمد
نعود اليك لاحقا دكتور خليل يعني انا
متاكد ان كثير من المشاهدين الان يودون ان
يعرفوا ما يعنيه ما تعنيه ادانه دونالد
ترامب او عدم
ادانته يعني ما هي السيناريوهات المحتمل
هذه القضايا اربع قضايا عشرات التهم قد
يستمر الامر لفتره طويله قد يدان يحكم
عليه بالسجن قبل ان يترشح على الرئاسه ما
هي السيناريوهات المحتمله
والارجح نتيجه لهذه المحاكمه
طبعا السيناري الارجح ان احنا ازاء فتره
ممتده عثمان لهذه المحاكمات يعني الصعبه
جدا توقع وجود يعني امر بات ونهائي في هذه
القضايا هنتكلم عن الحديقه تاخذ شهور وقد
يكون سنوات بعض الاوقات حتى رغم محاولات
بعض
المحققين الخاصين الدفع بها بشكل سريع
بشكل كما كما
المحقق الخاص في قضيه في قضيه ترامس او في
هذه القضيه سيحاول ان يقدم هذه المحاكمه
بشكل سريع كي يتم البث فيها شكلها لكن
ايضا حتى وان كان هناك متعلق بامكانيه
توجيه لاواح اتهام حقيقيه او اتهام حقيقي
من قبل المحاكم سواء الفيدراليه او
المحليه للترامب هناك سؤال كبير حول مدى
قدرته على ان اولا ان يستمر في الحاله
الانتخابات الرئيسيه ثانيا ان ياخذ
انتخابات الرئاسيه ثالثا اذا نجح في هذه
الانتخابات ما الذي سوف يحدث واذا تم
الحكم عليه مثلا بالسجن سواء سنه او خمسه
او عشره او حتى 15 سنه هل سيحكم امريكا من
خلال من وراء القطبان هذا سؤال كبير وهو
الذي يعتبر معضله لحد بعيد سياسيه
وقانونيه هناك الان فابته جدل كبيره حول
هذه المساله وهي المتعلقه بامكانيه ان
يقوم رئيس في السلطه ان يحكم البلاد من
خلف القضبان للاسف الشديد ليس هناك نص
واضح في الدستور الامريكي كل ما يتعلق
بامكانيه ترشحه الرئاسه الامريكيه يقوم
على ثلاث شروط ثلاث شروط رئيسيه الشوط
الاول ان يكون الشخص المرشح والرئيس ولد
على الارض الامريكيه ان يكون قد امضى بها
14 سنه من عمره والا يقل عمره عن 35 عام
وبالتالي كل هذه الشروط تنطبق على ترامب
بشكل كامل ليس هناك شرط مثلا متعلق
بامكانيه يصبح رئيسا اذا تعرض لاتهام او
اذا كانت هناك قضايا مخله بالشرف كما هي
مثلا حاله في العالم العربي لكن الوضع في
امريكا وضع معقد للغائب بل اكثر من ذلك
البعض يتحدث الان عن امكانيه ان يقوم
الرئيس اذا ما تم الحكم عليه ودخل السجن
ان يقوم باعفاء نفسي من هذه التهم لان
الرئيس الامريكي يمتلك بحكم الدستور
والقانون قدره على العفو عن المتهمين
جنائيا هل هذا الامر ينطبق ايضا عليه هذا
سؤال مهم جدا وبالتالي هذه المحاكمه لانها
محكمه غير مسبوقه في التاريخ يا استاذ
عثمان ليس هناك سوابق لها من الصعب جدا
توقع سوناريو محدد لها فيما تعلق بالبعد
القضائي وارد جدا يتم الحكم عليه وارد جدا
يتم ايداعه وداعه في السجن لكن سياسيا
الامر حتى هذه اللحظه غير واضح دستوريا
ايضا غير واضح وبالتالي نحن ازاء ظرف
تاريخي ظرف غير مسبوق على الاطلاق من
الصعب الخروج بالسناريو محكم ومحدد فيما
قد يحدث في المستقبل فيما يتعلق مستقبل
ترامب السياسي والقضاء والقانوني ما الذي
قد يحدث اذا سيد بيتر راف ما هي
السيناريوهات المحتمله وهل يمكن بالفعل
الجمهوريين ان ينتخبوا دونالد ترامب حتى
لو ادين وحكم عليه بالسجن
تقول في الاستطلاعات الاخيره ان ترامب
وبايدن يتنافسان بشكل متقارب في استطلاعات
الراي الرئاسيه نيويورك تايمز ليست بالفعل
داعمه للحزب الجمهوري
ان نقولها بتهذيب اذا دكتور العناني تحدث
عن بعض الامور الشائكه بالنسبه اولا
تم اليوم بالنسبه الى لائحه الاتهام هذه
الرئيس السابق الرئيس السابق ترامب ايضا
يقول ان هذه المساله تم النظر بها من خلال
مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ في المحاكمات
البرلمانيه وهو لم يدن على مستوى الكونجرس
الامريكي وبالتالي الادانه ان تاتي في
الجانب الق لشيء تم وهو في السلطه
التنفيذيه هو امر غير مقبول لا يمكن ان
نحاكم مرتين لنفس الجريمه يجب النظر بهذه
القضيه اتوقع انه بغض النظر عن نتيجه هذه
المحاكمه وانا ايضا ارى ذلك بالنسبه الى
قضيه الوثائق وقضيه على مستوى منهات في
مدينه نيويورك ان المحكمه سوف تجد ان
الادانه اذا ما حصلت هي باطله وبالتالي لا
يؤخذ بها قانونيا جزئيا لان المهبوله
ان اقاطعك انا اعلم جيدا انك ترى انه
سيبرئ ولكن ليس هذا سؤالي هناك احتمال ان
يدان وان يحكم عليه بالسجن في هذه الحاله
هل سيستمر الجمهوريون في ترشيحه
لانتخابه رئيسا
بحسب نظره معظمي الجمهوريين هو
المرشح الرئاسي لهذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه
هناك بعض الاسئله التي تطرح بالنسبه الى
انتصار الرئيس بايدن في العام 2020 ما اذا
كانت شرعيه ام لا هذه الانتخابات هذا لا
يهم لان الرئيس بايدن هو رئيس الحالي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه واذا ما ظهرت
ادله بان النتائج كانت
وانت تتحدث سوف يعني سوف تكبر حديثك سيد
بيت الرعب ولكن هذه الصور نشاهدها لموكب
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب وهو
يغادر اذا المحكمه الفيدراليه في واشنطن
ما نعلمه هو ان المحكمه حددت موعد جلسه
الاستماع القادمه في الثامن والعشرين من
هذا الشهر اذا يعني بعد ايام فقط ستكون في
الشهر الحالي الجلسه الاستماع المقبل احمد
هزيم يغادر ترامب اذا الان في الاغلب ربما
مترجها الى المطار
كما امرته القاضيه هناك بعدم الحديث
للشهود امرته القاضيه هنا بعدم الحديث الى
الشهور في هذه القضيه ما نحاول التاكد منه
عثمان هناك بعض ما تردد على مسمع هنا وانا
في هذا الموقع من انه لم يكن هناك فرد اي
كفاله على الرئيس الامريكي لكن هذه
المعلومه لازلنا بحاجه للتحقق منها تحديدا
لكنها معلومه متوقعه عثمان بان لا يتم فرض
كفاله على الرئيس الامريكي السابق وتم
تحديد الثامن والعشرين من اغسطس هي الجلسه
الثانيه في هذه المحاكمه اي ان كما طلب
المحقق الخاص شكسبيث بان تكون هذه
المحاكمه محاكمه سريعه القاضيه هنا
استجابت لطلبه لطلب الادعاء وحددت الثامن
والعشرين من اغسطس جلسه ثانيه في هذه
القضيه عثمان
شكرا شكرا لك احمد هزيم من امام المحكمه
الفدراليه في واشنطن اعود للضيوف سيد بيتر
رافع اعود اليك ما كان بامكانك ان تختصر
ايضا بعض الشيء قاطعتك قبل الذهاب الى
زميلنا احمد هزيم تفضل
صحيح فقط اجابه عن سؤالك انا افهم
السؤال الافتراضي بالنسبه الى السيناريو
بالنسبه الى معظم الجمهوريين لن نصل الى
هذه المرحله هذا ليس في حسابات الجمهوريين
بالنسبه اليهم هو الشخص الذي يترشح الى
الانتخابات المقبله هو المرشح الرئاسي
الذي يستحق فرصه اخرى لكي يصل الى سده
الرئاسه معظم الجمهوريين يدعمون كل تقريبا
ما يود القيام به وكل هذه الحملات وكل هذه
الهجمات تاتي في كل مره على سبيل المثال
هنتر بايدن يواجه المتاعب نرى الاتجاه نحو
ترامب اذا هذه الامور السياسيه وليست
قانونيه نحن نتحدث عن امور نراها الان نعم
ولكن هانتر بايدن لن يترشح للرئاسه فسؤالي
لك هل حتى لو حكم عليه بالسجن سوف يرشح
الجمهوريون الرئيس السابق دون تشام نعم ام
لا
هذا السؤال للسيد بيت الرعب
واعتقد ان الاجابه الان هي نعم نعم
ليس مرشحا رئاسيا ولكن هو مرشح رئاسي ومن
الواضح ان لم يكن صريحا مع الشعب الامريكي
بالنسبه الى دوره في اعمال هنتر بايدن في
بلدان خارجيه سيد جون بولجر هل هل وضع
الرئيس الحالي بايدن يساعد دونالد ترامب
انا اتحدث عن انه
ليس صغيرا في السن ولكن يبدو كبر السن على
الرئيس بايدن شاهدنا اكثر من صوره له يعني
يظهر عليه الاعياء بعض الاحيان كما يقال
هل المظهر الذي يظهر به الرئيس الحالي جو
بايدن يساعد
في البدايه لقد اشرت الى الرئيس بايدن
ومظهر رئيس بايدن وانه متعب ولكن اليوم
كان يقود الدراجه الناريه في دلاور اذا
يجب ان نذكر هذه الامور ايضا اذا لا يجب
ان ناخذ الانطباع السهل انه متعب وانه
تقدم في السن هو رجل في سنه وهو طبيعي
الرئيس السابق ترامب ايضا تقدم في السن
وصحته ليست جيده كثيرا اذا اعضاء في
الموظفين الرئاسيين عندما كان كان رئيسا
قالوا ذلك بالنسبه الى هاندر هنتر بايدن
ليست القصه الان اذا ما اردنا ان نتحدث عن
هانتر بايدن لربما في مناسبه اخرى يمكننا
ان نقوم بذلك ولكن ما قام به الحزب
الجمهوري هو ان اللجنه الجمهوريه الوطنيه
جعلت كل مرشح
يترشح للرئ من الحزب الجمهوري
وقع على
قسما بالدم بانه سوف يدعم المرشح الرئاسي
للحزب الجمهوري اذا اذا ما كان دونالد
ترامب عليه او عليها ان يدعموا دونالد
ترامب اذا نحن جميعا نعرف
كما الضرائب نحن لن نرى دونالد ترامب يدعم
شخصا اخر اذا بالنسبه الى زميل السيد رافت
في الجانب الجمهوري لقد تطرق الى سلسله من
الامور غير الدقيقه المساله الرئيسه هنا
والتي نركز عليها في المحكمه اليوم هي ان
الرئيس وجهت اليه لائحه اتهام مجددا
لتصرفات وانشطه غير قانونيه والرؤساء
السابقون يجب ان لا يقوموا بذلك
المشاهدون الكرام يجب ان يعرفوا ان هذا
ليس بالامر الطبيعي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهو امر غير تقليدي لم نعاهده
ونحن لا نود ان ندعمه في التصرفات
السياسيه دونالد ترامب يرى هذا الامر
وكانه لعبه كبيره الامن القومي والامن
الدولي والسياسات الداخليه وكل شيء هو حجر
في هذه اللعبه التي يقوم بها وقد قام بكل
هذه الامور وهو يشعر بالحصانه مقابل اي
تدابير قضائيه
سيد
بولجر اسمح لي يعني لم يتبقى وقت كثير
لدينا نحو دقيقه ونصف
ليعلق الدكتور خليل نعم ترامب هو الاكثر
يعني شعبيه في الحزب الجمهوري ولكن في
الولايات المتحده من الاكثر شعبيه
دكتور خليل
يعني من الصعب التوصل نتيجه حاسمه يا
استاذ عثمان في هذه المرحله حتى هذه
اللحظه يم تبدو حظوظ الطرفين متساويه طبعا
هذا يعتبر ايضا امر سابق لاوانه فيما
يتعلق الامريكيه للانتخبات الامريكيه من
الصعب جدا حسم او الحديث عن وجود مرشح
مكتسح على حساب مرشح اخر لكن بشكل عام
هناك بالفعل تراجع لشعبيه بايدن سواء
نتيجه عثمان فيما يتعلق بشعور البعض بعدم
قدرته وعدم كفاءته وعدم لياقته الذهنيه
وفيما يتعلق بعدم قدرته في التعاطف مع بعض
بشكل اقتصاديه رغم الاقتصادي المعقول جيد
خاصه في ظل ازمه الاقتصاديه عالميه نتيجه
عن حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وفضل الصراع مع
الصين لكن بشكل واخر هناك عدم ثقه فيما
يتعلق باداء بايدن ايضا النقطه المهمه هنا
وتدع عثمان نحن ايذاء ازمه حقيقيه فيما
يتعلق بالنخبه السياسيه الامريكيه النقود
الامريكيه تعاني على الاقل على مدار اخر
عشره سنه بوجود شخصيات ووجود وجوه فعلا
تكون جيده ومؤثره تتجاوز الاستقطاب امريكا
تعيش حلا او تع المرحله استقطابيه غير
مسبوقه على الاطلاق فيما يتعلق الهويه
فيما يتعلق بالقسام الاجتماعي لانقسام
الهوياتي وهذا الخلاف حول ترامب جزء من
هذه المساله يعتبر رمز انقسامي لحد بعيد
وبالتالي نحن اذا ازمه سياسيه حقيقيه سواء
في الحزب والجمهوري تنعكس شكل بقره على
انتخابات الرئيسيه المقبله سوف يتعلق بيضا
او فيما يتعلق نعم وبالنسبه لصحه بايدن
صديقنا جون بولجر يقول ان الرئيس بايدن
كان يقود دراجه ناريه اليوم في دلاور
واعتقد ان هذا سوف يكون صعبا علينا جميعا
انا وانت السيد في تراف والسيد جون بولجر
ليس امرا سهلا شكرا على كل حال خليل
العناني دكتور خليل العناني استاد العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه من واشنطن
وكان معنا من واشنطن
الكاتب الصحفي وعد اللجنه الوطنيه للحزب
الجمهوري وديفيد بولجر
مدير مكتب السيناتور جوزف بايدن السابق
والان الى وسيله عبد السلام ومنتصف